[Música]
al menos dos personas murieron en el
estado estadounidense de Iowa en medio
de un tiroteo perpetrado el lunes en la
misma jornada otras siete personas
fallecieron en dos balaceras registradas
en California los hechos ocurrieron Solo
dos días después del ataque en ese mismo
estado en el que 11 personas murieron
en el año 2022 fueron asesinados 215
líderes sociales e indígenas en Colombia
Se trata de la cifra más alta desde que
comenzaron los registros en 2016 la
mayoría de las muertes tuvieron lugar en
zonas donde hay presencia de grupos
armados ilegales
continúa la atención por las protestas
en Perú tras el violento allanamiento de
una universidad en Lima la capital en el
que unas 200 personas fueron arrestadas
los ciudadanos acusan al gobierno de
criminalizar El estallido social
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos donde dos estudiantes
perdieron la vida y un hombre resultó
herido de gravedad en medio de un
tiroteo registrado en de muán en el
estado de Iowa las autoridades
explicaron que el presunto responsable
un joven de 18 años tenía como objetivo
integrantes de un programa educativo
alterno para mantener a la juventud
lejos de las drogas y de cometer delitos
el herido fue identificado como el
fundador del programa tres personas han
sido arrestadas por su presunta
vinculación con los hechos
el lunes también se registraron dos
tiroteos en el estado de California
ambos relacionados y esto en la zona de
Half Moon Bay donde en total siete
personas perdieron la vida El presunto
responsable es un hombre de 67 años
además ascendió a once la cifra de
fallecidos tras el tiroteo del sábado en
Monterrey Park también en el estado de
California Edgar Costa enviado especial
de France 24 nos amplió los detalles
sucedió en la localidad de Monterrey
parque al este de Los Ángeles una
comunidad eminentemente asiática en la
que el propio perpetrador de la matanza
un hombre de 72 años llegaba aquí a esta
sala de fiestas armado y empezaba a
disparar ha sido pues la intervención de
la policía incluso de Héroes locales que
habitaron que hubieran más fallecidos
los que han terminado con la pérdida de
la vida del propio perpetrador de un
disparo que sería auto infligido las
autoridades del sheriff han hablado de
que no queda claro el motivo de este
incidente pero sí que han hablado de
munición encontrada en su casa
artefactos de elaboración propia para
poder llevar a cabo esta matanza el
hombre de 72 años también de origen
asiático americano pues ha perdido la
vida y sin duda reabre un debate que
siempre pues frecuente en momentos como
este donde vecinos y personas se acercan
a las inmediaciones de donde ocurrió la
tragedia para llevar flores ofrendas
velas y pedir a las autoridades que por
favor tomen cartas en el asunto que se
possiga de una vez por todas legislar
para que no pueda suceder algo así el
acceso a las armas el debate que nunca
termina en Estados Unidos continuamos en
Argentina donde el presidente Alberto
Fernández recibió a su homólogo
brasileño Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva la
reunión tuvo lugar a un día del inicio
de la Cumbre de la celac en Buenos Aires
en la que se espera una propuesta para
que haya una moneda común en la región
Nicolás Maduro confirmó que no asistirá
la cita estará marcada por una Nueva Ola
de gobiernos de izquierda el
narcotráfico cierto es un actor del
conflicto que más Gilberto da una clase
de memoria histórica temario que ha
llegado de forma las escuelas de la
alcaldía de Bogotá la historia de muchos
de estos estudiantes también está
marcada por el conflicto que a veces
llegamos a cuestionar muchas cosas de
Uy ustedes desplazado Uy Este es un
mural sobre el conflicto elaborado por
los alumnos del colegio de eleazapata se
hizo en 2022 con motivo de la
publicación del informe de la comisión
de la verdad que rinde cuenta de las
dinámicas del conflicto durante cinco
décadas el gobierno de Gustavo Petro y
Francia Márquez ha prometido
implementarlo en su sistema educativo es
el primer ejecutivo de izquierda en la
historia de Colombia y el primero de
este tipo en representar al país en la
celac un giro que llega hasta el estudio
de la propia historia enseñarles a ellos
es construir un futuro de cambio y de
paz
[Música]
después de 13 años en 2022 también hubo
cambio en Honduras con la proclamación
de Xiomara Castro como presidenta por lo
que la celac volverá a contar con la
presencia de un gobierno de izquierda en
Centroamérica una de sus principales
apuestas ha sido desde el deporte
remodelando decenas de instalaciones el
objetivo es reinsertar a niños y jóvenes
en riesgo por consumo de drogas
vinculación con maras y con el fin de
frenar la migración un ejemplo esa
bielsa gastumé que practica Kendo karate
muchos jóvenes se ha notado que han
hecho la diferencia han marcado una
diferencia saliendo mucho de alguna
adicción del alcohol de las drogas
[Música]
Erika Hilton es una de las dos primeras
diputadas trans en la historia de Brasil
el país donde más personas de este
colectivo son asesinadas en el mundo
según datos de la ONU tras la ausencia
en la última celac del gobierno de James
bolsonaro Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
devuelve a Brasil a la Cumbre y las
esperanzas a las diversidades
estamos reconstruyendo la narrativa de
la sociedad
es lilita que esta agenda avance pero
nosotras llegamos antes del gobierno
Erika Hilton por el rechazo familiar
tuvo que vivir en la calle a los 15 años
seis años después retomó los estudios y
se incorporó al movimiento estudiantil
hoy desde la cámara seguirá su lucha en
un Brasil que igual que gran parte de
América Latina ha girado a la izquierda
2022 fue el año con más asesinatos de
líderes sociales e indígenas en Colombia
desde que se empezó a tener registro de
estos crímenes en 2016 en total se
presentaron 215 asesinatos
Columbia marcó su triste récord de
homicidios de líderes sociales en 2022
la cifra más alta desde que se empezó
este registro en 2016 según el defensor
del pueblo Carlos Camargo esta situación
es especialmente preocupante ya que se
trata de líderes que recogen las
inquietudes de la gente no solo se trata
de cifras hay que pensar en 215 familias
duramente golpeadas y en las comunidades
afectadas que se quedan sin las personas
que luchan por sus derechos esto es una
grave afectación para la base de la
Democracia cinco departamentos fueron
especialmente afectados ya que coinciden
con las zonas con mayor presencia de
grupos armados ilegales nariño cauca
Antioquia putumayo y el Valle del cauca
reunieron la mitad de estos crímenes 63
de las víctimas eran líderes comunales
que generalmente promueven la
sustitución de cultivos ilícitos 47
líderes indígenas también fueron
asesinados seguidos por comunitarios
campesinos afrodescendientes sindicales
y activistas de Derechos Humanos esta
violencia está vinculada principalmente
con la persistencia de economías
ilegales fuertes en Colombia como el
narcotráfico como la minería criminal a
gran escala y también está vinculado al
fortalecimiento de grupos armados
organizados debido a la falta o la
ausencia de una política de seguridad
Clara en el gobierno anterior de Iván
Duque y también la falta de voluntad
política para implementar el acuerdo de
paz que tuvimos en el anterior gobierno
este lunes el eln valoró de manera
positiva los resultados de la reunión
extraordinaria que celebró con
representantes del gobierno colombiano
en Caracas tras haber desmentido el
anuncio de cese el fuego hecho por el
propio presidente Gustavo Petro la
defensoría colombiana Espera que dichos
procesos lleven a una disminución de las
acciones contra los líderes en Colombia
sin embargo en lo que va de este año ya
se han contabilizado asesinatos de
líderes sociales en Perú los
manifestantes acusaron a las autoridades
de criminalizar El estallido social las
organizaciones y diferentes sectores de
la sociedad peruana convocaron a una
segunda gran marcha en la capital para
este martes
no se vislumbra un final para las
tensiones en Perú ya están en libertad
los casi 200 manifestantes llegados de
todo el país que se refugiaban en la
Universidad Nacional mayor de San Marcos
en Lima detenidos después de que un
contingente policial irrumpiera
violentamente las instalaciones el
sábado por la mañana algunos estudiantes
denunciaron agresiones físicas de las
fuerzas de seguridad
uso estas palabras No vas a salir de
aquí me golpeó con su palo y me tiró al
suelo y empezó a patearme
Y es que las protestas que exigen la
renuncia de la presidenta Dina boluarte
continúan en la capital y el sur de Perú
con los manifestantes acusando a las
autoridades de criminalizar El estallido
social que deja miles de heridos y más
de 50 muertos directos en
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad incluido un policía y otros
nueve fallecidos por los bloqueos de las
últimas semanas las autoridades locales
por su parte justificaron el
allanamiento al campus universitario
pesa las denuncias de los organismos
humanitarios internacionales que uso
excesivo de la fuerza podemos informar
que la policía ingresó por actos de
flagrancia por la presunta comisión de
dos hechos haber ingresado al predio
universitario sin autorización Y en
segundo lugar por haber supuestamente
sustraído algunos aparatos electrónicos
de la universidad
este lunes al Primer Ministro peruano
Alberto declaró ante la fiscalía por las
muertes sucedidas durante las protestas
acusado de posible genocidio homicidio
calificado y lesiones graves Mientras
tanto sindicatos y organizadores de las
manifestaciones preparan una segunda
gran marcha de la toma de Lima para este
martes frente al informativo volvemos en
breve
[Música]